je suis aujourd'hui se trouve à tokyo
dans un autre appartement enfin parce
qu'en fait je me suis trompé dans la
première vidéo on était à osaka part à
tokyo si je vous parle bizarrement c'est
qu'actuellement ça pousse dans mon
intestin
je me suis retenu depuis à peu près une
heure le temps de rentrer dans
l'appartement pour vous présenter
attention les toilettes japonaises et le
petit panel de commandes
alors bien évidemment je les ai utilisés
avant la vidéo mais je n'ai pas utilisé
ces petites comment j'ai utilisé du
papier toilette comme on fait en france
et par tout le monde finalement je vais
un tout petit peu retardé moment je vais
me prendre sujet de dans les fesses en
vous montrant là on va tourner dans les
prochaines vidéos voilà soyez pas
surpris
ce sera notre bureau voilà donc le décor
ce sera à peu près ça voilà j'espère que
ça vous plaît allez c'est parti
ap ap hm clp du hockey bougeait pas
ottawa arrêtez de vous observez à
l'étude a été chaude
la chaude j'avais oublié alors ils sont
très malins en france pour la cuve était
chaud ça veut dire que tu passe juste
après quelqu'un qui s'est assis sur ce
trottoir et c'est très désagréable tu
avoir l'impression d'être salée de
frotter à ses fesses quand je fais ci
doit être fait et ensuite on va tester
ceci donc ça ça a l'air d'être le petit
jet d'eau ça ça a l'air d'être le gros
jets d'eau et ça le gie pour femmes
bon moi en tant qu'homme ça le juste ton
vélo sur les testicules s'il a
absolument aucun intérêt est la question
que je me pose c'est quoi peut donc
servir tous ces autres boutons bon c'est
un truc a sorti ok juste un bâton qui
est sortie acheter de l'eau dont le
savait rien ok il alors de tester ça
j'ai peur j'ai peur
mauricienne s'est placé comme un jacuzzi
quand c'est pas moi c'est sûr mais au
cayston c'est super bizarre je regardais
plus jamais japonais de la même manière
je me dirais que chacun d'entre eux
s'est pris un général than us auquel ol
2 c'est comme un jeu vidéo le gros j'ai
je serre les fesses si vous jure c'est
court parce que le principe c'est de ne
pas serrer les fesses justement est
maintenant le level 3 un pur et les
testicules n'y a pas un séchoir 1 ça me
paraît logique du trentin sous vêtements
a annoncé pour ça qu'il ya du papier en
fait quand même ok d'accord c'est pas
qu'ils pensent à nous pas du tout c'est
qu'ils pensent à la presse avant tout
pour se sécher
j'ai du mal à parler mais jamais voir un
traumatisme voyait ce que c'est
humiliant cette position la réponse est
oui il a écouté j'approuve ces toilettes
or rien n'est comme c'est bien fait je
tiens le château il ya le robinet du
dessus qui s'activent
je suis moi c'est pas fait pour ça mais
j'ai pas juste ce n'est pas le lot des
douanes qui luttent ils n'en seraient
complètement les villes attention les
explications de ce que je viens de me
prendre dans le cul à l'explication 2 1
ben voilà on ressort plein d'émotions de
cette expérience hors norme et ben
finalement j'avais une approche plutôt
négatifs de ces toilettes mais au final
c'est assez cool ça te retire tout et
puis tu as pu qu'à utiliser qu'une seule
feuille de papier quoi c'est bon pour la
planète c'est bon pour les arbres et ben
écoute et j'en suis fière fin de cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo si
vous aimez bien assassination castro ça
n'a aucun rapport peut écouter je
voulais vous faire découvrir ces
domaines avec moi j'espère que vous
n'aurez jamais l utiliser ces fossés
fois c'est pas si terrible aux côtés
dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir
gardé portez vous bien on se quitte sur
cette belle vue de tokyo complètement
invisible à vos yeux à cause de ce
reflet à la tribune pour tout bientôt
tout le monde puisse
oh